we now begin a whole new area of circuit
analysis called sinusoidal steady-state
analysis and you can also call it AC
analysis a C stands for alternating
current it means it's a voltage or a
current that where the signal actually
changes sign is positive sometimes is
negative sometimes and the conventional
name for that is AC or alternating
current it could have been called
alternating voltage but that's not the
name the name is AC so what I want to do
in this video is we'll do a quick review
of what it's like to solve an equation
like the one showed here this is an RLC
circuit I'm going to show what it's like
to solve this in differential equation
form which is going to be a lot of work
and I want to introduce the idea of a
new point of view or a new analysis
method that we refer to as the
sinusoidal steady-state and it's it's a
transformation that we're going to do on
this circuit and it's going to be a big
reward at the end and I want to go
through what's the reward and what's it
going to look like at the end then we're
going to know some of the math we have
to review in order to fully understand
this change that we're going to go
through this change of point of view so
let's first take a look at this circuit
here this is a circuit that's now a
driven RLC circuit so here's the drive
function it's a voltage it's some
waveform it's driving a sequence of
inductor a resistor and a capacitor now
in an earlier video we derived the
natural response of this circuit and to
do that we shorted out we remove the
source and shorten it out and added a
little bit of energy to this circuit and
saw what it did on its own what was its
natural response and now we've upgraded
this we've added a source and now we
have to solve this again including the
source if we use the differential
equation technique this is how we're
going to go about it so the first step
in a circuit analysis like this is to
write a KVL equation we're going to try
to file we're going to solve for this
current right here that's the one
current that's in this so i's our
independent variable so if I write KVL
as you recall when we did this for
natural response we ended up with a
differential equation that
like this we had L times the second
derivative of AI plus R times the first
derivative of I plus one over C times
times I so these are the voltages each
of these individual terms are the
voltages across across these components
here so that's the capacitor that's the
resistor voltage this is the capacitor
voltage and this here is the inductor
voltage so it's inductor voltage
resistor voltage capacitor voltage and
all those if we add those up those have
to equal V in so this is now a forced
equation which means this is the forcing
function and we're going to have to
solve this and the math for doing this
is pretty difficult it was hard enough
to do the natural response and we add in
this and it gets it gets to be even more
work so as we did before what we do now
is we propose a solution and the
solution we're in the habit of doing
this now it's going to be some constant
times e to the some natural frequency
times T so a e to the st is our proposed
solution for I as a function of time and
you remember we called s s is a
frequency term because it s times T has
to have no units so SS has units of 1
over time or frequency so that's called
the natural frequency
and when we plug in I the way the way to
tell if AI is a solution is to plug this
into this equation here and we got an
equation that look like this we ended up
after factoring out I we ended up with L
s squared plus RS plus 1 over C and all
that is equal to for the natural
response we put in so we solve this
equation by setting this term here equal
to 0 and solving for s to find out what
the natural frequency is and then we go
back and we find out a by looking at the
initial conditions over here whatever
initial energy was in this circuit
determines the value of a here the next
step in this forced response where VN is
driving the circuit is we have to set
this back to VN and solve for the forced
now if we let VN be sort of any any
forcing function we want any kind of
waveform this is going to be a really
hard piece of mathematics this is going
to be a really difficult calculation
it's going to take a long time and
basically I don't want to do it so I'm
going to wish there with some other way
to do these kinds of equations and there
is and the way we simplify this process
substantially is we make a little
limitation on ourselves on what VN can
be and if we make a rule if we basically
volunteer to limit ourselves to VN
equals sinusoids that means that V in is
of the form cosine of Omega T plus V
Rafi of some angle or it could be sine
of Omega T plus some angle any any any
waveform of this form here is called a
sinusoid so that's the sinusoidal
general name for cosine and sine and
signals that look like that and because
we don't want this math to blow up on us
with the general the general input of
over here we're going to develop a
really elegant way to solve circuits
where this we limit ourselves to
sinusoidal inputs and we'll take a pause
right here and continue on in the next
video to introduce the idea of
sinusoidal analysis